[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editor at the daily mirror of pippa
kurara and political editor at the sun
harry cole they'll be with us uh right
up until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the last stand is the headline in the
metro as ukrainian forces in mariopol
prepare for another onslaught from
russia but with their ammunition
starting to run low
the eye claims an exclusive with details
of what it says russia's plans to
resettle displaced ukrainians in the far
east and the arctic circle
the financial times reports that ukraine
is appealing for financial help totaling
tens of billions of dollars to plug the
hole in its economy left by the conflict
the guardian leads with an attack by
labour leader shakir starmer on
chancellor rishi sunak over his wife's
tax affairs accusing him of being an out
of touch hypocrite
the star describes the chancellor's
response to the controversy like this
mr stroppy
the express leads with a plea from
campaign groups for more help for
pensioners suffering from the huge rise
in the cost of living
the mirror focuses on the case of one
couple who say they'll never be able to
afford to switch their heating on again
the sun reports on the trial of a group
of men accused of robbing former
footballer ashley cole and his wife
the mail says that emergency plans are
being drawn up to avoid travel chaos at
ports and airports ruining people's
easter holidays
the times two leads with the fear of
travel chaos this coming weekend
meanwhile the telegraph says that gps
have been ordered to work longer hours
in order to avert similar chaos at
hospital a d units this easter
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and i'm joined tonight by pippa and
harry cole welcome to you both let's um
start with the metro um and this a sad
story but uh the headline saying it took
the jury only 18 minutes to unanimously
convict ali
ali the
murderer of sir david amis pippa
yes well it
it was only back in october wasn't it
that david demas was
murdered at his mp surgery and it
doesn't seem like that long ago really
that awful day
that really sent shockwaves through
westminster of course he's not the first
mp that's been killed
um in this way and uh you know in
previous occasions i think we've all
felt that the security measures which
we've brought in as a result
uh would go much further in helping
protect
mps but david amis is one of those who
regarded his interactions with his
constituents as the most important part
of his job
and carried on with surgeries right
across his constituency some mps had
decided to have them in their offices
instead where there's more staff around
and possibly more protections
um and
sadly back in october he was he was uh
brutally murdered by ali harbi ali and
as you say in many of the front pages of
the newspapers tomorrow also say
um he was sentenced and he was um he was
found guilty incredibly quickly by that
jury in just 18 minutes he showed no
remorse or contrition during his trial
and in fact
appeared proud of of his awful actions
um and he'll be sentenced to at its
later date but the judge has made it
clear that that you know he's likely to
face
a life sentence and and before he spend
the rest of his life behind
bars um you know really sad day for the
family that sat there the old bailey and
watched that verdict being passed and
you know that sadness won't go away uh
nor will it amongst many of his his
friends and colleagues right across the
house uh who felt who felt this whole
awful ordeal very very personally
yes a much loved colleague and the
further detail that that we heard harry
of um ali harbi ali that he was
self-radicalized
yeah the ultimate fear of uh somebody
who slipped through that so easily
because
they have done it to themselves online
the horrific details that um i think
scared a lot of people to westminster is
the number of years he spent planning
this um
this attack the number of people
including stammer including um michael
gove that he that he looked up he'd look
he'd been you know he'd been found to
have actually scouted out michael gove's
house he'd looked at the house of
commons and actually picked david amos
deliberately because of the lack of
security there it's just a horrible
feeling that you know on a friday
morning when mps go to their
constituencies their children their
families their you know partners
were thinking in the back of their head
you know will they come from home from
work um today slightly chirad slightly
sort
trial given that he had already admitted
it he clearly only um
pled guilty to get his moment in the
dock to spite uh to spout his bile but i
think the best thing we can do in this
scenario is ignore that ignore all those
things he said i remember david amos who
was um you know not everyone's cup of
tea politically a very socially
conservative man but a cheeky chappie
with friends across the political divide
and someone who's sorely missed indeed
the telegraphs pointing to the prevent
scheme which has been criticized this is
the counter-terrorism program because of
course ali harbi ali was known to the
police pippa
yeah he was referred to prevent seven
years ago and actually boasted that he'd
managed to basically
hoodwink those who were running the
devada colonization program by sort of
nodding and appearing compliant and um
you know the telegraph has done this
has looked at the
most recent terror incidents
on in the uk and established that you
know almost half of them
involve individuals who have been
through the prevent scheme and this
obviously raises
further questions about the scheme which
is already being uh is is being looked
at uh being reviewed but amid concerns
that it's actually not fit for purpose
and this is not this obviously not a new
development for some time they've been
concerned about prevent and whether it
actually does what it says on the tin
and is capable of de-radicalizing
individuals or whether some of them are
so sort of sophisticated that an
experience that they're able basically
to persuade those that they're working
with that's that they are um you know
they're no longer a threat um
obviously ali habi ali was one of these
he just had one interaction with with
prevent but there's no concerns and have
been for a long time to say that the
scheme is neither properly resourced to
make a difference nor indeed has the
faith of those that are that are
operating it and if it's becoming toxic
as the telegraph suggests then it
suggests that um that review which
already has been delayed and i'm not
expecting until the end of the year um
whatever it recommends is likely to have
to be be followed but then you're
looking at potentially years until those
recommendations are actually brought in
which leaves obviously the system very
vulnerable in the meantime
harry let's move on to uh ukraine and
the metro the headline there the last
stand and this is ukrainian soldiers uh
saying that they're running out of food
and ammunition um and this is the the
last chance to protect mario pole
yeah grim scenes tonight and some really
disturbing uh reports coming out of kiev
about possible use of
chemical weapons um in in in that siege
um as yet uh unconfirmed but the
ukrainians are pushing that story very
hard tonight
president zelensky is saying that that
has has not happened or either the
chemical it has not happened okay well
so it's a rapidly moving situation uh
online tonight but the problem was about
about a week ago when it was that um
you know the battle of kiev was was
essentially one but you know that is one
battle in a in what is shaping up to be
a very long war
in the fact that yes putin you know was
stopped in his tracks and turned on his
heels and has pulled out of the areas
around
kiev but however that has freed him up
although he's taking huge and
possibly embarrassing losses he does
still have a brutal army that can now be
sort of turned towards the east of the
country and perhaps you know dressed up
as a you know some victories there
dressed up as uh
as a way of saving face in this battle
it's gonna
the idea that this is any way over and
all the sort of briefings and and
remarks we've heard from
from sort of politicians and and defense
sources and like in the last of 10 days
is do not
get you know this isn't over yet and
there this is going to be a very very
long haul and i think maripola could be
the first of many uh of these awful
sieges that we're going to see unless
more arms are given to the ukrainians
and not just defensive arms aggressive
heavy arms that allow them to fight a
very different battle in the east in the
open ground versus the
almost urban warfare that they were
fighting north of kiev
harry and pippa thank you both for the
moment we are going to take a break
coming up more of tomorrow's front pages
including this in the guardian which
leads on criticism of the chancellor
rishi tsunam for his tax status by
labour leader sakir stama do stay with
us
[Music]
you're watching the press preview still
with me political editor at the daily
mirror
and political editor at the sun harry
cole welcome back to both of you let's
have a look at the guardian um an
out-of-touch hypocrite this is a sakia
stama's criticism of rishi sunak over
tax avoidance
deserved or not would you say pippa
deserved criticism or not
well you know this whole affair has been
an absolute gift to labour because it's
focused attention at a time when so many
people are struggling when the treasury
itself is himself has put up taxes put
up national insurance uh right across
the board that's come into force um it's
it's it's uh just at that moment he
appears to have
flouted um some of the the uh
i shouldn't say reflected the rules he
he stuck within the rules but uh plus
the spirit shall we say of um
contributing to tax
in the uk with um his wife's non-dom
status and questions still
uh continuing about how much tax
she
managed not to pay as a result on her
overseas earnings here in the uk some
suggestions around 20 million pounds
it's been a political disaster
for um richard synack so it's no
surprise that kiyostama is attempting to
capitalize on it there and you came to
keep the focus
um on it going into a into a second week
um and he raises the question in the
guardian interview there
about whether uh such super wealthy
politicians can really relate to the
public at a time when people
are you know
wearing extra jumpers so they don't have
to put the heating on and struggling
with
the price of their weekly shop
um facing huge bills as a result of
inflation
and pressure on prices uh because
somebody that has four houses has
admitted
using four different types of bread at
home and and you know
is such is so incredibly wealthy really
relate to
to how um how those people are these
families are coping whether they're
struggling or not noisy next said today
that he does understand that let's just
bring harry in on that because we're
we're running out of time we've got
about uh less than a minute harry um
is is the chancellor hypocrite or not is
it
deserved criticism
you can see as pippa says kirsten is
obviously having a field day on this um
i think it is
a thin line to be to be trod by the
opposition on this one without slipping
into
sort of all out soak the rich class war
thing which could end up almost sort of
tilting the the balance of sympathies
back towards uh star abs uh
uh sunak if it starts to appear unfair
there's been some quite unedifying
attacks but
almost based on the fact that because
his wife is indian um that uh this is
somehow you know it just
the balance has to be kept right the
first time actually this
this week star was the one trying to
make hay on this so the last weeks uh
sunak's been making this a disaster his
own making he was the one fueling that
story with threats of leak inquiries and
kepbrick and reporting himself to the
standards commissioner this is the first
time it feels like the the opposition
actually needs to say something to keep
the story alive whether they can do that
up to poland in the local elections in
may remains to be seen but um
i think it's happening
harry thank you very much and pippa will
talk much more in the 11 hour thank you
see